[Music]
hello and welcome to the climate show
with me tom heap and in a break from the
pattern so far i have broken out of the
studio because it is hot and dry several
days above 30 degrees c across much of
the country and now an official drought
in many areas too but you didn't really
need an official to tell you that we can
all see it and feel it it is
particularly stark here
graph from water a supply reservoir in
cambridge which is looking very low
i've got a little illustration here
these are little muscles that i picked
this up from the ground beneath me and
these should be underwater but as you
can see they're out here being baked and
frankly dead in the sun
well the parched earth is also visible
from space this is a satellite picture
of the uk
last summer
and now a recent shot
much less of a green and pleasant land
well fly a bit lower across the south of
england this week and this is what
you'll have seen
brown fields dried out riverbeds and
even the occasional fire
well this drought does spread across
much of europe in germany less rain just
doesn't just hit businesses on land but
rivers too the rhine is a major highway
and barges are becoming beached while in
france forest fires are rampant across
many square miles of the southwest we'll
have reporters in both countries
back here in britain much of our water
comes from underground rocks which acts
like a sponge but it's not a limitless
supply and our science correspondent
thomas moore is in somerset but he's
going down
well i'm standing beneath the mendip
hills and we've been following this
stream
down from the surface from swilden's
hole and as you can see the stream water
is quite low that's because of course
it's so dry on the surface but it's
joined at this point by a tributary
called rolling thunder now this isn't
surface water as such it's rain which
has fallen on the soil and then filtered
through the limestone rock and because
it's been so dry in fact the period
between november and july was the third
driest on record
there isn't much of the water here
and that is the worry this is ground
water and it goes on to supply the needs
of bristol it's drinking water
and across the southeast in particular
groundwater does supply up to
70 percent of the needs of water
companies comes out of
our taps and of course at the moment
it's really low and the data shows that
across the uk levels are below normal
for the time of year and in the south of
england
they are exceptionally low in places
because it has been so dry now water
companies say they they're all right for
now
but if we get another dry winter we will
be in a precarious position
next summer that's the point where
really things do begin to bite the thing
is that the soil above us is so dry
baked by the sun of course but it's
going to take a lot of autumn rain just
to get soak up that soil again before it
even begins to come down here into the
caverns below the mendip hills and
that's going to be a growing problem as
we go forward with climate change we can
expect hotter drier summers and these
groundwaters will take longer to
recharge over the winter and that could
mean that in future we do have periods
of drought
well back to me squinting in the
sunlight and on a day like today i'd
swap places with my cave dwelling
colleague like a shot
well now from the west to the east i've
been in east anglia looking at drought
solutions
the fear is with summers as hot as this
followed by dry winters
we might see that
taps running dry
so what are the potential solutions
first idea pump more water from where
it's plentiful in these massive steel
pipes
to where it's scarce
and that's what they're trying here in
lincolnshire with a run that goes all
the way from the humber estuary down to
colchester
when these pipes are connected they'll
be capable of carrying 84 million liters
a day a total of 250 miles the ticket
price is half a billion pounds and there
is an environmental cost too it's very
energy energy hungry energy intensive
especially across a flat region like
ours we use a lot of
uh pumps and pipes to move water around
and actually one of the considerations
we've made when we were building this
pipeline is how we can make it the most
energy efficient and the least carbon
hungry as possible
it is a massive project cutting through
fields and roads in a sweeping line
through east anglia but the company
insists it's essential we know that if
we don't move water around our region
taps will run dry and we're not talking
about in the next sort of 20 or 50 years
we're talking about in the next five
there's a water shortage across a large
part of england not just the southeast
have they got the water in the humber
area to spare to send down to east
anglia yes and that's the idea that the
water is more readily available up on
the humber bank um and by building this
pipeline we can increase resilience
right across the region you also pull
quite a lot of water out of the ground
in in abstraction is that going up or
staying the same what are the rules on
that so we've actually we're actually
lessening our abstraction um the amount
of water we take out of rivers but to
the tune of about 84 million liters um a
year in you know in the next five years
and that's because we will need to
protect the environment and actually
this pipeline will allow us to do that
and we'll be able to actually turn off
some of our river and groundwater
abstraction points as a result of moving
water via this pipeline around the
region
this project is all about moving water
what about catching more rainwater in
the first place
in reservoirs like this one at rutland
water the trouble is most of the ones
we've got around the country are running
low
so we're walking on what should be water
yeah so if the reservoir were full it
would be up here and you can see that
it's at the moment it's down here so
about 80 full a little bit lower than we
would expect at this time of year um
because we've been going through a
period of dry weather so it's absolutely
critical that we do have these stores of
water
i think i'm right this is one of the
last if not the last reservoir to be
built in this area yes so we haven't
developed reservoirs in this country of
this sort of scale since the 70s but we
are now looking at proposals for new
reservoirs um and i'm working on
reservoirs in the anglian region we are
proposing two new reservoirs they're
likely to be cited in lincolnshire and
the fens each one could cost one billion
pounds
what we do know is that they are going
to take a long time to develop so
they're really long-term projects we're
working what does that mean when is it
long-term so we're working on the early
proposals and early design work now for
water to be available at customer taps
by the late 2030s so wow so nearly 20
years of time really long time
changing land to lake is a very lengthy
costly business
which is also likely to upset some of
the people who live there
well those ways to deliver more water to
our taps are expensive controversial and
largely out of our hands so what about
the home front
where we use water is where we can save
it too
like this bold solution in the back
garden of a house in cambridge
the tank i'm standing in takes rain
water from all the roofs and it goes to
flush the toilets
a big project i'm guessing it didn't
come cheap so why did you do it um well
we did it as part of the the house
remodeling and what to save us a few
quid on
the
water bills and as an environmental
thing you know we didn't want to just
keep using water when there's free stuff
falling from the sky but mainly to save
water and a bit of money yeah and how's
that balance working out not too bad i
mean uh we'd save around 150 to 200
pounds a year uh in the cost of waters
and
um it's just nice to know that you're
using rainwater rather than the
processed water is there a bit of a
fielded factor every time flush
yeah
there is over well over a good wet
weekend it'll fill that tank with 5000
litres really in that time yes wow
that's pretty good and then you can
think free water free water
do you come across this sort of thing
no unfortunately not they're not very
common um generally because they're
quite expensive to fit and it takes a
lot of you know digging up your garden
unfortunately
the pressure group waterwise think it's
time to change our attitude to water
the mindset shift will be quite
difficult because we think of ourselves
as a wet country don't we it you know
umbrellas soggy glastonburys wet
wimbledons definitely i think everybody
when you speak to them they think oh
london it rains all the time but
actually there's less rain per head in
london than places like istanbul sydney
which is quite shocking when you speak
to people about it but i think we just
need to draw it away as not so much as
well about the weather and rain it's
just about water availability is about
population growth and how much water we
actually have available for not only
ourselves but the environment too
are the government doing enough to
promote water sailing
uh no to put it plainly i think there's
so much more that the government can be
doing and there's lots that we are have
pushed for in terms of trying to mandate
water efficiency in new homes and
obviously existing homes and businesses
we'd like to see mandatory water
metering across the country as well um
we'd also like to see a bit more
emphasis on the joint up
energy and water because by saving water
you can also save energy and thus save
carbon and we're finding that the two
conversations are very much siloed so we
would like to see those conversations
joined up and essentially mainstreaming
water efficiency into everything that
goes on so economic growth population
economic justice also social justice
everything like that there is a part
that water can play and we think that
the government can really step up and
help make a difference
steph hurry from waterwise there and
we'll have to wait and see how
vigorously the government grasp the
water saving nettle well it's worth
having a look at our website as well
where our data team has pulled apart the
stats so you can check local rainfall
and compare it to the past it's a clever
gadget frankly a weather nerd's paradise
just go to skynews.com or the sky news
app
after the break we'll hear from across
the channel some parts of europe have
got it even worse than us see you
shortly
[Music]
welcome back to the climate show with me
tom heap i'm at graphen water in
cambridgeshire one of the many parts of
the country which is now officially in
drought and the drought across europe
has been described as perhaps the worst
in 500 years and if my history serves
that would be the tudor period when
henry viii was doing his stuff
well in recent weeks we brought you
reports from trickling rivers in italy
and devastating fires across spain and
portugal now it seems it's france's turn
to bear the brunt hundreds of
firefighters have gone from elsewhere in
europe to the south west of france and
laura bunduck has been out with them and
seeing some of the fires yourself laura
tell me what's around you now
yeah well there were fires here back in
july and they caused a huge amount of
damage they only managed to put them out
a couple of weeks ago if you look behind
me you can see the damage done but the
problem is now the fires are back and
there is a clue behind me as to why
there is smoke rising up from some of
those tree stumps from the ground and
the reason the fires are coming back is
because this is peat soil it is
scorching hot and smoldering under the
ground here and that just means it
doesn't take a lot to see the pockets of
smoke joining together to creating more
to create more fires and that's what's
been happening and there is a real
problem at the moment you have the awful
combination of a drought and a heat wave
coming together and bringing the
conditions that make it very very easy
for these fires to spread
yeah and peat fires can be particularly
serious i mean i know across other parts
of the world they're very difficult to
put out they can smolder underground and
in terms of climate they release
carbon that's locked up centuries ago so
they kind of really matter don't they
it is the problem here the soil i think
and what we've seen is not only are
there 1500 firefighters not just from
france but right across europe battling
the main fires the big fires but we're
seeing villagers as well they know this
land well they know how these fires take
hold and we've seen them armed some of
them with big containers on the backs of
their cars others just carrying rakes
and spades trying to stamp out as
quickly as possible any pockets of smoke
like that one behind me because the
sooner they can do that the easier it is
to try and contain and control the fires
the peat soil here if you walk along the
edge of the forest not kidding you can
feel the heat rising up from the ground
it is absolutely scorching here and are
we yet seeing much damage to to homes to
property or other firefighters and the
residents as you described just about
managing to keep the flames at bay
well a couple of days ago it got really
bad and 17 houses were destroyed but i
think the firefighters would say we've
managed to evacuate most of the homes
the majority of homes that were really
under threat were evacuated nobody was
hurt seriously hurt in the fires but the
amount of damage it's done to the land
is just impossible to assess at the
moment this is very much still a live
operation they are at the moment damping
down this scorching ground at the moment
they're trying to create fire barriers
they're plowing up digging up huge edges
of the forest to stop the spread because
you have some roads which are completely
burnt out and then it's pretty pristine
on the other side and the worry is if
fire spreads to the pristine areas where
they can't access access it as well it
will become a massive problem and it
will it would take weeks and weeks to
control so at the moment as i say
the winds are starting to build and
that's the worry you've got these hot
strong winds building up this heat wave
40 degree or so heat at the moment all
of that making these fires difficult
exhausting and particularly
unpredictable and volatile
and just very briefly you kind of
answered it there but any end in sight
in terms of the weather in the next week
or so just briefly
i spoke to the chief of the fire and she
said to me we just live in hope there is
rain potentially forecast in the next
few days but she said i'll be honest
with you we need two weeks of english
rain if we were to properly bring these
fires under control
well thank you very much indeed it's a
very very powerful stuff well as we
mentioned earlier this is a europe-wide
drought meaning the continent's big
rivers are dwindling islands are
appearing in the loire and in germany
drought hits business too it is a vital
trade route there and jane secker is on
the banks hi tom well i'm at the rhine
germany's commercial artery this is the
river that transports goods up and down
the country and it carries everything
food fuel coal metal stuff for heavy
industry
cars we've seen them all coming past us
today on the river but where i'm
standing is not the river bank it is the
river bed uh normally there'll be water
here there'll be little fish swimming
around here but it is becoming like a
beach and as this is because there's
been no rain and the river levels have
fallen but as the river shrinks in terms
of width it also shrinks in terms of
depth and we've got these handy sticks
to show you
uh the big one is a bit it's admittedly
a bit high but it is about the depth
that then there is of water below the
ships normally it's about two and a half
meters it's normally about two meters
this
is what the current depth is in some
parts of the river under the boat so you
can see the problem
if you've got a ship with a great big
hull a barge that's very very low in the
water it just can't get past water
that's 40 centimeters deep and just up
the river from here
is the pinch point it's the narrowest
part
where the boats are having to to pause
and it's it's making a little bit of a
traffic jam up there because normally
they'd be able to come and go together
but because the channel is so narrow
they're having to come through in ones
and twos queuing up a bit like a traffic
lights and that is really slowing down
the freight on on the river
now in terms of the long term if you
look back to 2018 when the weather was
very very hot then it led to shortages
of fuel in germany they just couldn't
get a lot of the barges along this part
of the river and they are really
concerned that they're going to see that
happening again
this year
they're looking at solutions short term
they could do things like use the trains
that you can see behind me
freight is being pushed onto the
railways onto the roads as well long
term they're developing barges that have
got smaller drafts that the barges don't
sit as low in the water
but none of these solutions solve the
real problem which is the heat the lack
of water and the fact that this river
which is so key to germany's industry
and its gdp
is literally shrinking
before their eyes
tom
thank you jane well we are zigzagging
about all over europe today and now
we're going to go to our energy and
climate correspondent hannah thomas
peter who's in the west country our own
west country that is hannah what have
you been up to today
we've been visiting coliford reservoir
which is on boardman moore in cornwall
it's only 40 percent full it's
cornwall's largest reservoir and so
you know that's a problem and we went
down to the water's edge and it was it
was quite frankly spooky the receding
waters are revealing all kinds of things
that have previously been hidden haven't
been seen for decades since the area was
flooded uh to create this reservoir um
the outlines of old field systems and
clay pits and tin mines and old tree
stumps are sticking out of this
quicksand like uh sidelines now to the
lake uh and it's one of the reasons of
course this region along with many
others in the uk
has been declared to be to be in a
drought but frankly speaking to the
people here they didn't need that formal
declaration to know that this area is
absolutely part and in desperate need of
rainfall
i i'm quite interested in hannah in sort
of chewing over with you sort of how we
got here and what the future holds both
in terms of policy and in
climate change because it seems to me in
the last few decades the sort of
emphasis in terms of water policy has
been mainly about you know principally
about keeping price down not of a lot of
investment into the resilience of the
system making sure the supply is good
we've hardly built any reservoirs in the
last uh last 50 years or so
it's interesting that isn't it and and a
lot of people are saying that the the
new reality of climate changes is coming
home to roost and i think potentially
it's really a matter of focus
you know i think we can we can safely
say that for politicians and policy
makers and for the public the big
conversation in this country has yes
been about a heating atmosphere but in
association with dramatic rainfall and
so politicians have been really
preoccupied with what to do about
flooding which communities to help and
protect which areas to leave alone um
which areas may no longer become livable
i mean billions of pounds of new
spending has been announced
in the last couple of years about how to
tackle that problem we've all come to
accept that our winters are extremely
hotter and wetter i think there's just
been less of a conversation about
everything getting hotter and drier
well i know one group that particularly
has been pleading for that conversation
for a long time people can concerned
with rivers the rivers trust and the
anglers as well have have been pointing
out that a lot of our rivers have kind
of turned into lengthy puddles that
there's very little flow there the
levels are artificially maintained some
of them i think it's uh three are incred
sorry six around the country from the
rather in yorkshire down to the waveney
here in in uh in suffolk or away to the
east here and others as well are
incredibly low and they say the
environment's been paying the price for
the fact that we've just been kind of
sucking so much water out of the ground
and really suggesting that can't
continue there are some tricky questions
here for the for the public as well
aren't there about our own behavior
yes as well as the importance i think
that's absolutely right of managing you
know for example wetlands better which
we're told by everyone who's white on
these matters are both the solution to
to helping communities deal with
flooding and the solution to helping
communities deal with drought
but there's also this difficult
conversation to not just to do with
supply and investment in new pipe works
and so on and but to do with our our
consumption of water just as there is
now a big conversation about consumption
of energy uh you know why doesn't
everybody in the uk for example collect
rainwater as a matter of course why
hasn't there been a big public messaging
campaign around all of that and the
answer i think is that as a number of
people who work in this policy space
have said to me you know britain still
thinks of itself as a cold country and
we've got to get over that because it is
not the new reality that we are now
fighting
yeah
yeah
yeah
indeed well it looks like when it comes
to these natural resources we're going
to have to
value them and indeed husband them well
hannah thank you very much indeed
thanks
and of course we'd love any of your
questions you can scan the qr code here
or go to the right place on our website
next week we'll be talking energy are
there some big green solutions to our
energy crisis spoiler yes at least in
the long term and just before i say
goodbye
i'm going to put this up
keep the sun off me cheerile
[Music]
you